The politicians can pretend it's
something else,
but Donald Trump calls it radical
Islamic terror.
Right now,
I don't want to talk politics.
I don't want to talk about who you
should vote for or whose campaign ads
are more effective.
What I do want to talk about is how
campaign ads brainwash you using 100
year old film making techniques.
The technique is called the montage,
and it was one of the first visual
storytelling techniques and film to
start.
Let's watch the most famous montage of
all time.
So here's the question.
Do we ever actually see Marion Crane get
stabbed?
The closest contact the knife makes is
right here.
That's it,
but with montage,
with a series of images moving rapidly
across the screen,
you can convince the viewer they see her
stabbed repeatedly.
The scene consists of quick shots of the
knife,
Marion's body and Marion struggling and
screaming when seeing those images all
at once,
we associate the images with each other
and create a story in our brains of what
we saw.
Essentially we got brainwashed.
Now the third way is what one might call
pure shit.
Imagine the assembly.
All all bill and how come beat chain to
create a different idea.
Here's another montage in citizen Kane.
In 1941,
it tells the story of Susan Cain being
forced to perform across the country
under the pressure of her husband,
Charles.
Okay,
here's a more contemporary montage with
two people shooting up heroin.
We didn't actually see anyone do the
drug,
but the assembly of the images told the
story for us.
Now we have a closed up.
They would show what he listens to.
You saw a woman holding a baby,
and
now we come back to his reaction to what
is smile now?
What is he as a character?
He's a kindly man is sympathetic,
so let's see how campaign ads do it.
The world a president has to grapple
with.
Sometimes you can't even imagine.
That's the job and she's the one who's
proven.
She can get it done.
Securing a massive reduction in nuclear
weapons.
In Hillary Clinton's new world campaign
ad,
we cut from the White House and it's
long white pillows to Hillary Clinton
walking in front of more long white
pillars to her walking off the plane to
her talking with Vladimir Putin.
Now these editors have thousands and
thousands of pictures of Hillary Clinton
to choose from.
For this commercial,
it is no coincidence that they chose an
image of the White House and then three
clips of common activities and locations
we associate with presidents,
the walking by the White House pillars,
the leaving Air Force One,
the talking with other world leaders all
reinforced with the use of the phrase
that's the job.
These editors are using a montage of
images to make us Imagine Hillary
Clinton as president.
When we see her working hard in these
familiar spaces,
we imagined her filling those same shoes
and see her as a president in a
positive,
familiar way,
but montage and campaign ads can also go
from positive to threatening.
Now,
let's take the middle piece of film
away.
The woman with the child,
but leave his two pieces of promos.
They will.
Now we'll put in a piece of film of a
girl in a bikini.
He looks
good in a bikini.
You smile.
What is he now?
A dirty old man.
He's no longer a little bit nine
gentleman who loves baby.
That's different.
That's what film can do for you.
All right?
More not just abroad,
but here at home with the clear and
present threat of radical Islamic
terrorism.
On the march,
we must secure our borders.
Washington continues to fail us with
groups like the gang of eight that
support amnesty and allow sanctuary
cities.
This video shows radical terrorists and
illegal immigrants in a menacing,
dark green tint,
followed by the capital in front of a
thunderstorm,
followed by Marco Rubio.
This montage,
along with the tent and grainy found
footage.
Look cinematically associates,
Marco Rubio with something Americans
fear the most terrorism.
The montage manipulates the audience to
see Rubio at has policies as terrorist
friendly.
What immediately follows is Ted Cruz in
bright saturated light speaking in front
of a large crowd,
surfing as a metaphorical savior to
Marco Rubio.
In the first half of the Commercial
America needs Ted Cruz.
The one proven conservative for
president,
uh,
Donald Trump ad uses a similar technique
by fading out from Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama to Muslim looking people
and an ambulance carrying an injured
person in the background.
Yeah,
the politicians can pretend it's
something else,
but Donald Trump calls it radical
Islamic terror.
These montages are carefully assembled
to associate Clinton and Obama with
terrorism,
with the right images in the right
order.
You can create whatever emotional
response that you want.
I want to make it clear that this video
is supposed to be nonpartisan.
Republican ideology allows for more
brutal campaign ads because they want to
show Democrats are soft on terrorism,
democrats to be just as brutal because
also portray Republicans as vicious
warmongers.
Think about it,
I would bomb the out of home.
One of these republicans carpet bomb
them into oblivion,
could actually be president.
Here we see a montage generalizing the
Republican candidates,
keeping them in low saturation,
low quality footage,
and physically shrinking them in small
aspect ratios,
and of course Hillary's clips are bright
and take up the whole street aid who can
stop them?
Hillary Clinton.
I wouldn't be surprised if Hillary
campaigners made a montage of wounded
soldiers like Nixon did in one campaign
out in 1968,
never had so much military and
diplomatic power been used so
ineffectively as in Vietnam.
The point is that the assembly of images
is extremely powerful.
Everybody does it,
and it's not just limited to movies.
This form of cinematic brainwashing
happens all the time,
not only in campaign ads but also other
commercials.
Beer commercials don't sell beer.
They sell an idea and that idea is
conveyed through a montage of people
smiling,
being social,
and having fun,
so know that more goes into campaign ads
than you might've thought,
and remember not to just vote for the
candidate who's editor.
Put images together the best.
My name is Jack Newton and I approved
this message.
Thanks for awhile.
Slightly full.
Just a bit of a break from the norm.
Just a little slot in the break,
but may not need a ball bat hot.